first on CBS this morning best-selling
author John Grisham is sharing some big
big news about the new sequel to his
debut book you remember a time to kill
and not only that he's also releasing a
new novel it's called Camino winds
haven't have a copy right here it's the
follow-up to Grisham's 2017 bestseller
that was called Camino Island the new
book tells the story of what happens
when a hurricane and a killer
both threaten a beautiful island John
Grisham joins us from his home in
Charlottesville Virginia
there he is good morning to you John
Grisham I want to start right away with
this book because it's a bit of a
departure for you I'm not giving
anything away because it's in all the
literature you're an author and you
write about killing off of it about
killing off an Arthur and that struck me
because I'm thinking if I wrote a book
about TV anchors I wouldn't kill off
Anthony and Tony you threw me a little
bit with that why'd you decide to go
that way
well good morning Gail tony anthony i
it's a sequel to camino island that i
published three years ago when i
finished that book i knew i would go
back there for at least one or two
stories because i like the setting I
like the characters and over the years
I've killed off a lot of lawyers and
judges I thought it was time to kill off
a writer but I just don't think of
people of killing off one of their own
though John that's what I was thinking
the New York Times Book Review says this
it's a Camino this is a Camino book with
elements of a more traditional Grisham
thriller thrown in so what did you enjoy
about stepping into the murders onra in
this way so it's a it's a tumor it's a
murder mystery it's it's we all love
murder mysteries and I haven't written
one of those in a long time usually when
I write about a murder you know you know
who did it but off the bat and they go
to trial but this was a pure mystery and
and I went to drop Clues along the way
and solve the crime at the very end so
that's what a good mystery does and it's
centered around a bookstore - I know
books are very important to you and book
stars in books
- yeah the principal character Bruce
cable from the first Camino Book owns a
bookstore on Camino Island in the town
of Santa Rosa in Florida and he's quite
a character
he is colorful and weaves a lot of books
sells a lot of books and the guy who
gets murdered is one of his friends it
happens in the middle of a hurricane the
police were too distracted to
investigate the crime so Bruce sort of
takes it upon himself and a couple of
buddies and they set out to solve the
crime and prove it was a crime and
become their kind of like grown-up hardy
boys off you know chasing the killer
yeah yeah that's a really good way to
describe it let's go back to 1989 for a
second John cuz guess what I read back
in 1989 the name of the book was well a
time to kill was published in late 1989
nobody read it back then it was a total
flop when he came out it wasn't until
the firm came out two years later in the
Pelican brief the client that people
really started reading a time to kill so
it's this the best-selling book of all
of them by now but I've gone back seven
years ago I went back to Ford County
with Jake Brigance and
the book called Sycamore row and that
was very popular and so now I'm going
back this fall with a book call a time
for mercy that involves Jake back in the
courtroom again in Ford County and Jake
was played on screen by Matthew
McConaughey we all remember that movie
very well I want to go back to Camino
for a second because on page 106 it says
it takes a disaster to make you
appreciate the basics so I'm wondering
what you're appreciating these days I
love that line you know you appreciate
the basics you appreciate your friends
and family you appreciate I appreciate
books I appreciate health and Renee now
we're talking this morning you
appreciate the things that remind you of
what's normal like the people you trust
and you know we were talking about you
guys they are the three of y'all we
watch you every morning and it's nice to
have people you trust
deliver the news that you can believe
each morning and so it's for you guys
it's it's something that's normal for us
it means a lot yeah thank you for saying
that cuz we are really glad to be here I
think it's draining and emotionally very
difficult but we what all of us wouldn't
want to be any other place and you talk
about appreciating friends last night
you and Stephen King who's a friend had
a virtual had a virtual event what was
it why did you do it how'd it go rather
and why'd you do it we did it because we
know each other very well we've been on
stage several times together for
fundraisers and library functions and
you know different things and we always
have a great time together
because our friendship goes back 25
years and we decided to do a virtual
chat last night on YouTube and for a
whole hours two of us and ask each other
questions and take questions from the
audience and you know as always the hour
flies by we have a great time talking
about books and writing and movies and
the process of writing and taking
questions and baseball and families and
everything it was it was a lot of fun I
hope we do have I know John I'm so sorry
we couldn't see when person next time
because I know we will see you again at
our table we all can't wait thank you
john grisham thank you very much thank
you okay thank you
whatever you want mr. Grisham whatever
you want take care be safe that's about
him thank you John Grisham thank you you
too